this morning screenwriter director and
now novelist david kepp
kepp's work has fascinated moviegoers
for a long time he wrote the screenplays
for jurassic park
mission impossible spider-man and many
more films that have grossed more than 2
billion dollars now he's on his second
book aurora already being turned into a
movie
it imagines a very real scenario but one
hardly anyone thinks about something
that would change life as we know it
it only took a couple pages until we
were hooked
see looking through the solar telescope
you
see how much activity and how intense
the sun's busyness and power is
every day
two or three times a day
the sun throws off massive clouds of
electromagnetic plasma
they are called coronal mass ejections
or cmes
firing off from spots on the sun's
surface
you can't see them with your naked eye
but you can through a telescope hiya hi
hi which is what we did at the
vanderbilt mansion planetarium in
centreport new york
i am looking at the surface of the sun
right now right face on wow
what are the black things just like
little black dots so those are the soft
spots oh they are yeah oh each of the
sun spots that you're seeing is about
the size of earth or bigger
so i see one two three four like four
and a half five sunspots right now
wow it's an idea that has been in my
head for a long time i'm
really interested in the notions of
powerlessness you know both literal and
metaphorical this book
scared the out of my life
well that was not my intention what he
did intend was to explore what happens
to those cmes normally they drift off
into space and they're never heard from
again
sometimes they'll have a glancing blow
on the earth and mess
with the electrical grid a little bit in
1859
it was a direct hit
in 1859 the only electrical systems in
white use were telegraph machines
repairs were made in days
today electric power is the backbone of
life for 7 billion people
scientists believe direct hit cmes that
would wreak havoc on the grid system
happen on average once every 150 years
since the last one was in 1859
we are overdue
if a cme hit the earth head on today
how long would power be out for
the short answer is 12 to 18 months
12 to 18 months without power
leading to a dissolution of society as
we know it
imagine with frightening consequences in
kepp's book
aurora my thinking was god if it
happened today and the grid went down
around the world for an extended period
of time
that's terrifying we don't know how to
live any other way anymore kepp's novel
begins in aurora illinois
just a couple hours from where he grew
up in pewaukee wisconsin
his father owned a billboard company his
mother was a therapist
he always knew he wanted to write
stories
where does he think he's going
when you gotta go you gotta go one of
his earliest screenplays also happen to
be one of the most successful
adaptations
ever made hey hey dan freeze
you were 29
when you wrote jurassic park is it nutty
to think about i so didn't know what was
happening and you know you can't it was
my fourth movie
and it was good it wasn't something you
need to be embarrassed of then a part of
you thinks oh this is how it's gonna be
now
and i have had a wonderful career and
had other movies that connected with
audiences
but nothing quite like that
cap has written or co-written the
screenplays for the first mission
impossible
[Music]
the first spider-man
and carlito's way mr pegante the second
time you turned me down for a drink well
you don't like my champagne hey it could
be
where's lisa though there have been some
misses
including
a little excessive but
i like it
mordecai
and the 2017 version of the mummy wow
that was intense
is it more helpful for you to think
about the successes
or the failures
unfortunately your mind goes to the
failures a lot it's hard not to think
that as the writer or writer director
it's mostly your fault because you're
the one who said wouldn't this be a
great idea
and the answer to the question turns out
is no
but it motivates you
oh totally i mean my number one goal
with a movie or a book is to avoid
public humiliation that's like the
baseline if i can get past that then
everything else is gravy it's part of
life there's it's like ups and downs
yeah absolutely it's it and it's not
a brian de palma's been a good friend of
mine for 30 years and i had a movie
early in my career come out that
wasn't gonna do well
he put his arm around me and said kid
you haven't lived until you've taken
down a whole studio
for kemp aurora is more than just
another potential hit in his long story
storytelling career
it's a warning about the ever-present
danger of cmes
what we have not done is
anything to prepare for that so that it
doesn't happen 12 to for 12 to 18 months
what can we do
it's called hardening the infrastructure
we know when when cmes are
coming from the sun we know how strong
they are we can measure their radiance
we can predict to the minute when
they're going to hit the earth
and really all you have to do is be able
to take the grids offline
um before they hit but hardening the
infrastructure
costs money it certainly does and but
you see the risks if we don't you know
the the texas blackout of 2021 was
because there was a lot of snow and it
got really cold and the grid texas has
its own grid and it collapsed and people
died there have been some improvements
but not
nearly what there needs to be which
isn't a fortune but it has to be spent
in advance of a problem and it's very
hard to prepare
for a problem that hasn't happened yet
as people
i think the whole military term we
always fight the last war right you
never know what the next disaster is
going to be 12 to 18 months frightening
the dish coming up next
[Music]
i started telling my wife about this
book
and the disaster planning went into
effect
in a big way it's unreal start taking
the cash out of the bank
well cash actually so you ask cap about
what what to do so and this plays out in
the book as well cash is a huge thing
right we're so dependent on credit cards
nobody cash cash money becomes a big
thing when disasters hit and all this
happens i mean the red line the big
thing is water they say a gallon of
water per person per day you should have
some water some supply of water the
other thing he said you know it
depending on where you live it's you
want you need some sort of warmth you
know so they
somehow space heat or something there
are like solar chargers now that can
power things up i mean he does have a
solar charger that's a good solar
charger is a good one um you know he did
say it and this is from coming from a
guy who lives in the city he said after
disaster
one of the first things you want to do
is get out of the city right right find
an escape plan it's interesting i was
telling you guys before the show i've
been watching a show that's about
katrina which we talked about earlier 17
years ago you listened to the beginning
of that before katrina hit and the
problems that happened after and what
that warning was at the end it costs
money to to make sure that they're ready
for something like this
same thing with katrina there were so
many things of oh we should do this with
the levy system we should do this things
that didn't get done because of the cost
that could have made a difference it
always seems impossible until it's
happening and then you start thinking
about why didn't we do this why didn't
we do that
haven't lived till you've taken down a
studio jeff give